Prof: Now I have--to--I
must tell you that I have very
bad news for you.
It has nothing to do with the
exams.
It's that I've been talking
with my economist friends and
what they tell me is that you
are inferior goods.
They even tell me that Yale
students are probably among the
most inferior of all goods.
Of course, I put on my
naÔve face and said,
'What are you talking about?'
and this is what I learned.
You take--I hope I've learned
to bring my--This is a standard
economics kind of diagram.
What it shows is the amount of
clothing that an individual
buys.
If they're very poor,
they buy at the Salvation Army
Store and they spend a very
little bit or they buy very few
clothing.
When they get rich they go to
Brooks Brothers and buy suits
for $1,000 and that's probably
an underestimate of what they
actually spend.
As their income increases,
the amount that they spend,
or the number of things that
they buy, increases.
All a very standard kind of
thing.
The ratio, there's an extra
little fillip to this,
not wildly important for this
course.
How much this line increases
for a particular change in
income is called the elasticity,
how big a change there is.
In clothing,
you really don't need an awful
lot of clothing to put on,
but you can spend a lot on it.
I know myself that when I was a
graduate student,
I used to buy all my clothing
at the Goodwill Store and now
that I'm a professor I have a
little more income and I don't
buy so much at the Goodwill
Store,
but it's still a great place to
buy things and I see the other
graduate--
the graduate students know
exactly what I'm talking about.
Really, clothing has a big
elasticity, but food down here,
you know you really can't eat
that much more food.
We try, of course,
but we don't succeed.
So no matter what your income
is, if you--certainly if you
measure the food in pounds you
don't eat an awful lot more.
If you measure it in dollars
you can buy caviar and live on
caviar, but basically there can
be a high elasticity or a low
elasticity.
That's one of the clear and
simple ideas of economics and
I'm sure it's nothing new to
you.
Now can you think of a counter
example to this?
Something that as people get
richer they buy less of.
Student:  Spam.
Prof: What?
Prof: Spam. Good.
Cheap food.
What's--that's a generation
ago, so how many of you have
ever eaten Spam?
You went to prep school or
something, right?
I have never eaten Spam,
but McDonald's hamburgers are
one of those kinds of things.
For people in a poor country,
like rice.
What do they go from--brown
rice, unpolished rice is what
the poor people eat or in India
millet and then when they get
more money they go to polished
rice or they go to wheat.
In all countries food is one of
the important things that you
eat up higher on the food chain.
You change what you want to eat
depending on your income and you
can eat less of what you
previously did.
Public transportation is
another example of goods that
you buy less of as you get
richer.
If you get richer,
you take a taxi or you have
your own limousine and a
chauffeur and so forth if you're
really wealthy.
All of these things do the
opposite thing to that.
Economists have a word for that
kind of a good and it is?
Student:  Inferior.
Prof: Inferior, good.
Now what's another example of
that?
You guys.
One of the most robust
phenomenon in the world is this
fact.
Poor people have a lot of kids,
rich people have very few kids.
This works no matter how you
spin it.
You can compare a poor country,
so take any Sub-Saharan Africa
country that you want,
to a rich country take any
European,
American, Japanese country that
you like;
if this is income across
countries, as they say
cross-sectional,
this is very,
very true.
If you look within a country
like--pick any country,
the rich people tend to have
fewer children than the poor
people.
Also you can spin it a third
way with time,
if you look at when a country
was poor,
they'll be having a lot of
children and then,
as they develop economically,
they get rich,
they have fewer children.
This is an absolutely robust
kind of data.
One of the--yeah--
Student:  What if you
measured value of children by
investment per child?
Prof: We're going to get
to that later.
That's at the end of a lot of
intermediate stuff.
This is the number of children
that you get,
it's not how much you're
spending on them but the number
of children that you have.
You have these three different
ways, you can have a high slope,
a low slope,
and the slope can even turn
down.
This is some real data
for--this is the total fertility
rate and going from one,
or even less,
up to eight children and this
is the gross domestic product
per adult,
and this is the log of it
because it goes over six orders
of magnitude.
That's--some places earn an
awful lot more so there's not a
linear scale but a log scale.
Over that whole range you can
see some very good correlation.
Those countries which have poor
income, have a lot of children,
and those that have a lot of
income have few children.
This is two different periods
in time,
1960 which is really before the
third world fertility transition
and 2000 when you're in the
middle of the third world
fertility transition and you
have these points for the 1960--
the circles,
the pluses are for 2000 and you
see there's--
what's happened is they've slid
down this line,
the countries have slid down
this line.
They're still pretty much the
same relationship but the
countries progress and their
income goes up.
This is the regression line for
1960;
this is the regression line for
2000, a small difference.
It's not--it hasn't changed
very much, so again this is
really a very robust kind of
thing.
If you compare countries a 10%
increase in per capita income
equates to a 13% decrease in
fertility.
It's a very interesting thing;
you have big culture
differences between countries.
Within a country where you're
under,
more or less,
if you have a homogeneous
country,
more or less the same culture,
the freedom of people to change
their fertility--
to control--to choose their
fertility is much more limited
within a culture.
Now if you look only within a
country you get a much smaller
change, a 10% increase in income
correlates with only a 1% change
in fertility.
So it depends exactly how you
run your statistics,
how big an effect this is but
it's absolutely robust,
we always find it.
Here's a great term paper for
you, or even a research paper
for the summer or something.
It's usually--this is with
respect to the Yale students.
It's usually presumed that the
families of Yale students
generally have a very good
income.
Probably even within--I mean
Yale tries to get a distribution
of incomes but within each class
we probably do very well so
we're a high-income group.
It's probably also true that we
generally have very few
children, that your families
probably each have very few
children.
You can take a ratio of family
income to number of children and
that ratio for different groups
is probably a measure of how
inferior you are.
The higher the ratio income to
number of children tells you how
much parents don't want children
because they have a lot of
income.
Guess who has this data?
Where have you filled in this
data?
Admissions office;
if you applied for a
scholarship which I think at
least three-quarters of you
apparently do,
some sort of financial aid,
they have income data on your
family and they also have the
number of siblings in your
family,
all that is data that they have.
If you can get it out of
admissions you could really do
some very interesting study of
what is that ratio for Yale
students.
Then once it's published from
Yale, every other school in the
country is going to try to do it
and it'll do for different
works.
I haven't seen these kind of
things published,
that this ratio for various
special socioeconomic groups.
This is kind of a surprising
phenomenon that rich people
buy--have fewer children.
One year I taught this course
and there was a guy in it,
a somewhat older guy who was
actually already a professor in
Kenya,
but he had come to Yale for
more education and he took this
course.
After the course he told me
that he was just blown away,
that he had never realized,
coming from Kenya,
that poor people had more
children then rich people.
Actually he put it the other
way, he had no idea that one of
the aspects of being rich was
that you have fewer children,
and he was a college professor
or a university professor in
Kenya.
This is quite,
actually quite shocking.
You heard, I mean our whole
cultural story is that parent's
love children,
parents want children,
well they want them,
maybe they love them--well not
when they're teenagers of
course.
You would expect that more
income would be an enabling
factor, a very big enabling
factor, that you'd,
in general, have more children.
But it isn't the case.
Well this is--anomalous things
are of great interest to
scientists,
including social scientists,
and so economists of course
have paid a good amount of
attention to this.
The way they talk about
children is that they try to
generalize,
just the way scientists try to
generalize things,
make Newton's Laws apply to
everything,
whereas before they were a lot
of different things,
so they try to do use the same
words they use for suits or food
for children.
The kinds of things they say
are that children are "a
time intensive commodity";
they take a lot of time to
either enjoy or bring up
properly.
Women's value of time is a key
component in "the price of
children",
that children have a price like
any other good.
The time--this is all quotes
out of various recent articles.
The "time cost of children
and other household
production",
children are one of the things
that households produce.
Then they talk about the
opportunity costs for households
to "produce and consume a
child".
I love the idea of what parents
are doing is consuming you.
I will put on the web an
article by Jonathan Swift,
the same guy who did
Gulliver's Travels,
you know this article?
A Modest Proposal,
exactly;
this is tongue in cheek on his
part but at that time,
much earlier and much later,
the English were concerned
about the Irish problem.
The Irish were very poor,
they had tons of kids,
and they didn't like to be
ruled by England,
so the Irish problem had to be
solved.
What Swift suggested was that
the Irish eat their children.
This would provide good food
for them, a lot of protein and
everything.
So, it would solve their
starvation problem and it would
reduce the population problem
there.
Of course this was tongue in
cheek but it makes really
interesting reading and
especially his--
notice his use of--if you
bother to read it,
it's not required,
his use of numbers.
It's full of numbers;
it's a real takeoff on what
fairly contemporaneous people,
like people starting to write
economics, were writing.
This idea that economics deals
with children just as they do
with any other commodity,
it's the genius of economics to
be able to do that,
just as it's the genius of
science to be able to make
generalizations.
But it's also one of the
reasons people reject the
approach.
They just--people generally
don't want to consider
themselves commodities.
Why should people want fewer
children as they get richer?
Well the basis of essentially
all modern economics is rational
actor theory,
that people act to maximize
their happiness,
-- or utility,
or preferences,
there's a lot of different
jargon words with slightly
different meanings,
-- and they don't act against
their self interests.
Now there's new psychological
economics, or neural economics,
which finds out this isn't
really true, but that doesn't
matter.
Most theory depends on rational
actor theory.
So economists believe that
people decide what to do,
based on a calculation.
It doesn't necessarily have to
be a conscious calculation,
which is a little problem
there, of what's good for them
and they act that way.
Somehow economists have to
figure out why is it good for
people who have money to have
fewer children?
Why is it in their self
interest?
Actually a guy wrote a paper,
Gary Becker in 1960,
and then he got a Nobel Prize
for this,
for bringing family--what they
call family economics into the
mainstream of economics and
treating children like any other
good.
Some of what I'm going to tell
you really comes from Becker's
theory.
As I mentioned,
one of the fundamental ideas is
that it costs money to rear
children,
and so they can be considered
an item to be purchased,
and so they call them a good,
anything that you purchase is
called a good.
There are different kinds of
goods and children are--all of
them or at least most of them.
They're a production good like
a machine.
A production good is something
you buy, like a machine for a
factory to do work.
And children,
of course, especially in poor
settings, do various kinds of
work.
We'll come back to each of
these things.
They are also a consumption
good, a consumption good is
something that you buy and maybe
eventually use up but you enjoy
it.
You buy it because you get
pleasure in some sense out of
having that, not because it does
work for you.
The third thing is,
they can be an investment good.
You put money into a child when
they're young,
and then when they're older you
get something back for it;
a return just like putting
money in a bond,
you put it in and then you wait
some time and you get,
presumably, more back.
First consider children as a
production good,
which is very largely the case
in poor countries.
One thing that's pretty obvious
is a child does not cost much to
make;
it's pretty cheap.
In a peasant family children do
a lot of work for the family.
They can run errands,
they collect firewood,
they can fetch water,
they take care of younger
children,
they weed the fields,
there's a whole bunch of things
that children will do.
You have some readings on that
in today's readings.
They actually do a lot of work.
Here's an example,
"little Baz,"
the name of a kid,
"can run all over,
fetch up cows out of the stock
fields,
or oxen, carry in stove wood
and climb in the corn crib and
feed the hogs,
and go on errands down at his
grandma's."
Guess where that description
comes from?
Could be anywhere in the world,
it happens to be a Kansas
settler in the late 1800s.
In America, like other places,
in the farm economy kids do an
awful lot of work.
There's a saying from Indonesia
that, by age seven,
a child does more work for the
family than the family has to do
for it.
To study that,
sociologists,
anthropologists,
economists actually go out in
the field and observe in peasant
societies.
The professor or graduate
student stays with the family or
stays very--
in the same village with the
family and always carries around
a clipboard,
one of these clipboards.
What they do is,
they write down everything that
the parents do for the children
and everything that the children
do for the parents.
Mom is cooking,
sister is washing vegetables,
little brother is sent to the
neighbors for a bit of cooking
oil,
baby just defecated,
mom stops cooking to clean up
the baby, etc.,
etc.
You can imagine all this down
on a clipboard.
That's when a child is young;
the family puts a lot of work
into the child.
As the child gets older they
require less and less from the
family and they start doing more
work for the family.
So economists--you can
calculate, or anthropologists,
anybody can calculate a
crossover age.
What is the age at which
children do more work for the
family, measured say in hours,
than the family does work for
the children?
It's no longer quite as young
as the 7 that the Indonesians
talked about,
but modern calculations show
it's something like at age 13
children are doing more work in
an agrarian society,
children are doing more work
for the family than the family
puts in to them.
In your reading packet is a
story about Tanamani,
from Malaysia,
and every year students ask--
it's a wonderful story,
you'll love it,
why do I put that in?,
and of course it's child labor.
It shows you what--how
exactly--a little bit unusual
instance but how children are
viewed,
it is not romantic at all,
it's a straight economic
calculation,
you maximize the amount of work
that you get out of a child.
Jonathan Swift I think mentions
age 6 as the age when children
can begin earning money as
pickpockets and David
Copperfield was sent to work
apparently at the age of 10,
and Charles Dickens himself
went to work at the age of 12.
Currently calculations from the
United Nations International
Labor Organization shows that
there's something like 250
million children aged 5 to 14
that are employed and half of
these children are employed full
time,
not as casual laborers but as
full time.
This estimate,
this is not a decreasing
phenomenon but this estimate is
up from earlier ones of 73
million children,
so from 73 to 250 million,
child labor is apparently
increasing quite significantly
in the world.
Agrarian societies,
just from the work that
children do,
children can be an economic
benefit and so people want a lot
of them to work around the farm.
Even in the early stages of
industrialization children are
often sent into earning work
where they earn cash and in real
poverty situations,
in industrially developing
countries,
even the small wages of
children can make a sort of life
and death difference in the
survival of the family.
Notice that this all changes
now when modernization comes in.
One of the things that happens
is children go to school,
and if they go to school,
they have fewer hours to work
at home so--their benefits go
down.
Money has to be provided for
tuition, for books,
for clothing or uniforms,
for shoes.
Children on the farm often
don't have shoes but when they
go into the city,
to be proper,
they usually have to have
shoes,
so their costs go up,
their benefit goes down,
and their cost goes up.
Another aspect of
modernization:
medicine becomes available.
Now if a child gets sick,
the parents have to spend money
on doctors or on medicine,
or they perceive that they have
to do such a thing.
If the family is in the city
and previously--
and there get to be a lot of
children working,
but there are also a lot of
adults out of work,
the government eventually puts
in child labor laws and says
children can't work and it makes
it illegal and therefore you
can't--
children can't work at all,
their benefit goes down.
All of these things act to
reduce the value of children as
production goods;
they're just not as good a
production good as they used to
be.
Now consider children as a
consumption good,
again that's the pleasure or
fulfillment that parents get out
of having children.
One article I read talks about
children as a consumer durable,
that's because they last a long
time,
and they're like refrigerators
they last a long time,
they're a durable good and you
see the reports every month of
what--
of how many more or less
durable goods are being bought.
It's very interesting because
the purchase of durable goods,
you don't usually pay cash for
that.
They go on a credit card and an
easy payment plan for later
payment and it's the same for
children.
They don't cost anything--they
don't cost much to make and the
costs come later.
I'm thinking the child is kind
of a like a house.
If you're poor,
you can or could until the
recent debacle,
buy a house with no money down.
So you don't have money and you
get a mortgage.
It's later on,
after you have the house,
that you have to,
every year, pay off the
mortgage.
You've got to maintain the
house, insurance for the house,
taxes for the house.
The upfront cost is very small,
later costs are high.
As you know,
a lot of people enjoy shopping
very much and then once they
choose,
they say this is what I want,
and they get a big bang out of
the actual purchase.
Making children is very
similar, people enjoy the
foreplay and then they get a big
bang.
Well that didn't work very well.
Ok.
So, another aspect--finally got
it--another aspect of this is
children as consumption goods,
and this has to do with
modernization.
You can't consider goods
separately, one from the other.
People have a certain amount of
money and what they buy will
depend not only on the cost of
each individual good but on
their relative costs.
What happens when a country
modernizes with respect to
children is that the cost of
children is perceived to go up,
education, health,
all these--clothing--
all these costs go up
inexorably, but at the same time
the cost of manufactured items
goes down.
Radio player,
television, any of the goodies
that you spend an awful lot of
time with.
As time goes on,
technology improves,
the cost of those goes down.
So modernization increases not
only the absolute cost of
children but more,
even more intensely,
the relative costs because as
their costs go up,
the costs of other things that
people want go down.
That's another cause why people
might want fewer children as
time goes on.
Another aspect is the time cost
of children.
An important idea is that
people have not only limited
income,
which they can spend as they
choose,
but also a limited amount of
time and we all use the phrase,
spend their time,
and economists take that as a
serious issue and they think
that time is spent in a rational
manner.
Time can be used for leisure,
time can be used for parenting,
or if the person works time can
be money,
it can be used to work and earn
money,
and each person has to balance,
or each family has to balance,
these things.
Most of the time,
and I'll show you some data on
this, required for childrearing
is spent by the mother.
In fact, almost exclusively in
most societies,
the mother does all--basically
all the work.
In the peasant society the
mother does all the housework,
everything at home is generally
done by the mother and this time
is not valued at all.
Mostly in peasant cultures,
women's work at home doesn't
count,
she may do the--she and the
children may go out into the
fields and do an awful lot of
work weeding and everything,
and also again culturally,
this usually just doesn't
count.
Women's time is not
particularly valued in
traditional societies.
In traditional times,
she can't get a job,
so she's not going to be able
to get--there are just no jobs
available for her.
Then modernization comes in and
jobs become available in the
cash economy and cash is what
people value.
Cash in an agrarian society is
so rare, so difficult to come by
that that's what is really
valued.
Jobs become available and in
many industrializing situations,
and especially in the third
world now,
the first jobs that become
available are low skilled jobs
like sewing.
Almost every country that
enters into the modern world has
started its "industrial
revolution"
by sewing jobs in factories;
Bangladesh, Indonesia,
all over the world sewing is
the first kind of thing and this
is largely a women's job.
You see this in China,
all over the world,
that some of the earliest jobs
in the modern sector are for
women.
Assembly--you look at
assembly--pictures of assembly
lines and almost any electronic
goods, who's doing the assembly?
Very largely women are doing it.
Once job opportunities become
available then you start--you
set up a competition between
childbearing and working;
when childbearing the woman is
at home,
she can't be out in the city
working,
and her time is spent taking
care of the children,
and therefore she doesn't earn
an income,
or she can have fewer children
or no children and go to work
and earn income.
Modern--what happens is the
opportunity cost to women,
which was considered
essentially zero in traditional
times,
starts rising as jobs become
available for women,
the opportunity cost of having
children rises.
That's another thing that as
modernization precedes you might
expect that families want fewer
children.
As modernization proceeds
people get richer and all of
these effects might really not
be due to the income but just
time going on in the way that
I've been talking about,
the changes that modernization
brings.
Now the third kind of thing
that we have to consider for
children is to consider them as
an investment good.
That means you pay now you,
get a return later.
Of course the value of children
doesn't stop,
but once they grow up,
if the culture has strong
families,
and that's a very important
'if,' then the children,
when they grow up,
will perceive that they have a
responsibility toward the
parents and that they have
responsibilities to support the
parents in old age or even
before old age.
It's interesting to note that,
if there's no stock market in a
country,
or banks, and poor people
really don't have access to
these things in most places at
the earliest stage of
industrialization,
there's nothing else for people
to invest in.
There's just no market for
things, there's no market for
their savings,
because rats and insects eat up
an awful lot of food,
you can't really store the
food, so basically almost the
only mode of investment is in
children,
so children are indeed,
in pre-modern societies,
very much an investment good.
This is brought home--I mean I
read a lot about this but the
experience of it in the
developing country is very
interesting to hear.
We had a graduate student,
he was from India,
and he was from an upper class
family and his family had only a
few children and all his
relatives,
his whole class,
the people he really knew had
already done their fertility
transition,
had very few children.
He was a good hearted soul and
wanted to help poor people,
so he worked--before he came to
Yale--
he worked in an adult literacy
program,
that's really one of the best
things that you can do,
and this particular program was
aimed at the very poorest people
who were still illiterate.
In the course they discussed
everything, because you need
vocabulary, you need to discuss
it, so there's a lot of
discussion as well as reading.
One of the things they
discussed was family planning;
in fact, a nun had been
speaking in the class strongly
in favor of family planning
trying to convince them that
they shouldn't have so many
children,
that they would be better off
with fewer children,
which was the experience of his
social class.
One day one of the adults took
Anand, this guy,
aside, and said,
"you know you are wrong
about family planning.
I have no money to save for
retirement,
there's no social security,
the government won't care for
me in old age,
and I need a son to care for me
in old age.
I have ten children,
if even one of them survives
and becomes successful,
then I will be lucky and have a
comfortable old age."
That was very nicely put what
the man said to Anand,
But there's also Anand's
reaction was also very
interesting.
That even though he grew up
in--and he had never thought
about that before,
he never heard about it,
he'd never thought about it,
he never perceived it form the
point of view of a poor person
and he was very impressed.
When he told me this story,
he said he was just amazed at
how compelling the argument was
and he couldn't think of
anything to say back to the
person in support of his
previous views.
Again, for the very poorest
people about the only strategy
they have for old age is to have
children who will take care of
them,
and in most cultures that means
a son will take care of them.
Kids cost very little in a
poverty stricken culture,
they wear hand-me-down clothes,
they don't have toys or lots of
anything like that,
they get basically no school or
medical care,
the kind of food that poor
people eat is fairly cheap and
interesting in terms of time,
beyond the first child,
the first and second child,
as soon as they get up to be
five, six,
seven, they start taking care
of the younger children,
so the time burden on the
mother sort of goes away once
you have somewhat older
children,
and older means like five,
and they can start strapping
the baby on their back and going
around with the baby so that
extra children are not--
don't even cost much time for
the parents,
they cost very little money,
you already have all the
hand-me-down things,
so it's just a subsistence
amount of cheap food that the
child needs.
It's--children are a very small
cost and they're a benefit as
old age insurance is perceived
to be quite, quite great.
What happens as
modernization--so parents are
basically willing--
poor parents are willing to
invest the little bit that they
have and a little bit that's
needed in a lot of children.
How does modernization affect
this investment?
If jobs start to be available
in the cities and/or
possibilities open up for
migration abroad to jobs,
all the people from India and
Pakistan,
they go to the Middle East to
work in oil related jobs,
to the rich economies;
people come to America to find
jobs.
They all send back remittances;
at least the first generation
is very, very good about sending
back remittances,
which is a huge fraction of
poor people's income.
Even though the remittances may
not be a huge fraction or what
they're earning in America or in
Saudi Arabia,
in terms of the income that
their parents are living on,
and poverty stricken,
it can be a very,
very big increment to their
income.
Children can be a really good
investment, if they can get a
job in the city,
or get a job abroad,
they're a really good
investment.
Modernization increases,
everything else it
decreases--the value of
children, but modernization
increases their value;
this aspect of their value as
an investment.
Several other things happen
during modernization that
increase the value as
investment.
First of all child mortality,
the first thing in a
demographic transition,
or usually the first thing that
happens is a quite severe drop
in infant mortality.
What that means is children now
are likely to grow up.
Previously children died very
young or died at various times
in their young ages,
and if something is going to
disappear,
like if something is going to
get stolen from you,
you don't try to buy a really
fancy car if you're pretty sure
it's going to get stolen and
it's the same thing with
children.
If the odds are very high that
your children are going to die
it's really not--
and if modern medicine isn't
available --
it's not really a good idea to
put a lot of investment into a
child that's going to die.
As modernization--some ideas of
sanitation,
public health come into play,
and the expectation that
children will live increases,
and then there is a longer
period for them to live and
return income to the parents.
The other side of the coin is
pretty much the same;
the parents are living longer.
In the old style of fertility,
married people just kept having
children until they became
sterile at 45 or something like
that,
and then at the old life
expectancy they didn't have much
longer to live and they were
still capable of working at 40,
45 and then they die.
Even if they have children that
stay alive, there's not a long
period of dependency where
they'll get income from their
children.
If you have your last child at
say 40 or 45 then they're going
to reach maturity when you're 60
or something,
almost 60 and that's at or
above the life expectancy in
very poor countries.
The increased longevity of both
children and parents make it a
much better deal to have
children as an investment good,
because there's a longer time
they can pay you and you're
going to be around for a longer
time to get this.
As opposed to the other ways
that children are looked at
economically,
as an investment good
modernization can massively
increase the value of children.
That would be--we have
counterbalancing--
if people have more money as
modernization goes on,
you think they could afford
more children,
but they become less good as
consumption goods,
they become less good as
production goods,
but they come much better as
investment goods.
Of course as people have more
money, they have more money that
they can save,
and one of the ways they save
it is by investing it in the
children.
One of the issues then is if
the value of children is now
mostly as an investment good,
how do you maximize this
investment?
In agrarian societies there are
really no opportunities outside
farming, that's what the society
does, period we're done.
If, indeed, the agriculture is
traditional,
you're doing it exactly the way
your grandfather did it,
and his grandfather did it,
and that's a very safe way to
farm because you're on the edge
of survival.
If your crop doesn't grow
you're in big trouble,
so if you try something new
there's always a danger that it
might not work.
If you do something the way
it's been done for hundreds of
years or thousands of years or
you perceive as thousands of
years in your family on your
land,
you're pretty sure that it's
going to work.
You may not get an awful lot
out of it but you're sure it's
going to work.
Peasants are very conservative,
not only about their
production,
their agricultural production
but everything else in their
life because they don't have
anything extra to gamble with,
so they're not going to take on
anything new.
The old way of doing it,
the father passes it onto the
son exactly as he has been doing
it.
You don't need an education to
do farming in a traditional kind
of way;
you learn it while doing it
with your father.
When education gets
modernized--when agriculture
gets modernized,
there's fertilizers,
there's new varieties of seeds,
you have to pay attention to
money and when you enter into
the market economy you have to
have some mathematical abilities
to know about money,
you may have to borrow money,
there's interest rates,
there's payback schedules,
there's all kinds of things so
that education starts becoming
very valuable,
even in agriculture.
Early on, the combination of
not needing education and the
probability that the kids will
die young,
there's really not much benefit
in investing in education in an
early agricultural society.
The best strategy at that time
is to have a lot of children and
put a minimal investment in each
of them and hope that some of
them don't die,
and that's in fact empirically
true,
that the investment before the
demographic transition,
the investment that people put
into their children was indeed
very small and subsistence
carried on the way it always
was.
Now population increases
because foreign foods come in,
all kinds of things happen,
and population starts
increasing, land becomes scarce.
Now imagine you have a small
farm and you yourself are living
as a subsistence farmer,
and you've got a whole bunch of
kids,
and now you're faced with
dividing up your land among the
kids.
Well you know the kids aren't
going to be able to do it,
you can barely do it on your
size farm as you divide it up
among two,
three or so sons,
and it just isn't going to work
so you're in crisis.
When the kids inherit such a
little bit of land not only are
they going to have big trouble,
but they're not going to have
any excess to provide for you,
so children,
stop becoming children if they
stay in the farm economy,
stop becoming any kind of a
decent investment to keep you
going when you're getting a
little old so you've got to
figure out what to do,
you're facing a crisis.
The outside economy is
modernizing,
you may not be modernizing but
the outside economy is
modernizing,
and jobs become available,
largely jobs that require some
sort of education;
white collar jobs,
the government jobs.
Big, huge bureaucracies spring
up, that--
I'll mention that in a little
bit --
and parents rather rapidly
realize that the only option is
for the kids to go to the city
and get a job.
But, all the parents,
everybody reaches that state
pretty much at the same time,
so the cities are just flooded
with people coming in looking
for the still scarce jobs.
How do you have an edge up?
It has to be education,
that is the only way you can
get these white collar jobs,
you absolutely need an
education.
In manufacturing jobs you do
better, you have to deal with
machinery;
you have to know things about
machinery.
I was in Peru quite a ways back
and they took peasants off the
Altiplano,
this high dry plain where
there's no water,
the land is terrible,
and they live on about $1 a
day.
In order to get a job in the
mines,
the first job is you take a
shovel and you--
there's big machines that eat
away at the rock face but a lot
of it drops down,
and they need people with
shovels to get the rest of it
and dump it into the trucks,
so this is really a minimum
skill labor job.
They needed to have two things,
which not everyone had,
1) to know that machines can be
dangerous,
that they can get hot from
spinning around,
that they can be electrified,
that you don't just touch
something unless you know what's
going on.
The second thing) you have to
know enough about time to get to
the job on time every day;
the shift comes on,
you've got to be there.
The peasants don't come knowing
those sorts of things and those
that do know those things can
double their income to $2 a day,
if they can get jobs.
That's even the most basic kind
of job requires a kind of
mindset and educational thing
that you don't get generally on
a farm.
Education becomes an extremely
valuable commodity.
But, in order to get the job
and to stay alive,
kids have to be healthy,
so you have to put money into
education and you also have to
put money into health for the
kids that's the prerequisite.
If you have a bond,
like a kid, you've got to have
a safe-deposit box for it,
that's like health insurance or
healthcare for it,
otherwise it's going to
disappear on you.
This investment in children,
which in education and
healthcare, becomes a very good
deal;
that if you can manage to
invest that much in your child
and go to the city or go abroad,
get a good job,
and their income will be so
much more than yours that they
can send you back a significant
amount.
These investments in children
are called human capital,
or the result of them is called
human capital,
it's the health and education
of the population.
It's now realized that when
economists study "why is
one country rich and one country
poor?",
well part of it is their
physical, their stock of
physical capital.
Physical capital is the
factories, the machines,
the buildings,
and all the stuff that you can
knock on.
They've realized that that's
not the biggest difference,
the biggest difference is
human--what they call human
capital,
how educated and how healthy
the population is.
So it's a very big thing.
An interesting thing,
we have two different factors
that are now in play,
why a child becomes a good
investment good.
One, with education they can
get a higher paying job,
and with better health they can
live longer and the parents can
live longer,
so they're paying you back not
only at a higher rate if they're
educated and healthy but for a
longer time period.
We normally think of that
things add,
well you get a certain benefit
from their education,
earning more per year,
and you get a certain benefit
from their health,
they're living longer and you
might be tempted to add those
two,
but in fact they multiply.
That you're getting a certain
extra amount per year over 30
years or something like that,
so the two factors multiply and
that's one of the really big
things in Becker's theory is how
these factors that go into the
increment a child will bring in,
the health and the education
multiply with each other and so
even fairly small increments in
either one lead to a very big
return;
multiplication is a very large
effect.
The end of this that as an
investment good,
investment in children's health
and education is very rewarding,
it's a really rewarding kind of
investment in the kind of
economic situation that we've
been discussing.
Here's the catch,
that if you're poor you can't
make these investments in a
whole lot of children,
and so the best strategy,
instead of having a lot of
children and dividing up your
assets among a bunch of them,
you have a very few children
and you concentrate your assets,
you concentrate what you can
invest in a few children,
and you get them fairly good
healthcare and as good an
education as you can get for it.
Children that have these two
things,
it's called the quality of the
child,
again that's another economic
jargon term,
that the health and education
of a child are the quality of
the child.
The way this change that goes
on in the demographic transition
is called the switch or the
trade off from quantity to
quality.
Before the transition parents
want a lot of children because
the main thing they're worried
about is the probability that
they're just going to die and
there's nothing the parents can
do about that,
the local folk medicine is
almost totally ineffective so
the kids are just going to die
kind of randomly,
but as time goes on that's not
true anymore,
they can do something to keep
their kids alive and they get
the kids educated so that they
can earn a good rate of income.
There's this trade,
a switch from wanting quantity
to wanting quality in the
children.
Parents catch onto this very
quickly,
some of the very rapidity of
some of the third world
fertility declines has been due
to that--
when the land gets filled up by
people it becomes very obvious
right away that you've got to do
something and the only thing
available are jobs in the cities
and--
they know very well that the
kids need education to compete
in that job market.
In terms of policy you get some
really interesting kind of
conundrums.
One is, education is what the
people want,
they want it desperately and
yet if they keep having eight
children,
the country is going to be
hopeless,
so policy makers like the idea
that in order to get an
education people have to reduce
their fertility,
but they also with good hearts
want to make education free.
The question in a developing
country is how much to charge
for education.
Its a very, very major issue
because you need to strike a
balance between--
setting the price low enough so
that you can get a lot of your
children educated,
yet setting some price so that
it's an incentive to parents to
not just absolutely flood the
system and overwhelm everything.
Wherever you set this ,
parents will always use
strategies to maximize their
benefit.
One of the kind of strategies
that people worry about,
that parents can do,
is the first child stays at
home,
second child stays at home,
eventually that child grows up
and starts doing work and then
they can do the work around the
house that's needed,
and the weeding the fields and
the work on the farm.
The third child is now,
in a sense, surplus,
you don't need their labor.
If there's free education you
get them educated,
send them to the city,
and you can do that if there's
no cost to getting a child
educated third,
fourth, fifth,
sixth there's no limit to the
number of children that you
could have,
you send them all off to the
city, they send you back money.
Same with healthcare,
that if you have a welfare
government and it doesn't set
this just right,
if healthcare is also free or
nearly free,
then again there's no cost to
having the extra children,
people may continue to have
that many children and then the
whole system just gets flooded
and you have a failed
experiment.
Education and healthcare are
some of the fundamental
variables in this relationship
between economic development,
jobs becoming available,
and how many children that you
have.
In developing countries,
as you know,
there are a lot of people,
labor is cheap,
but capital is scare,
they're not rich,
they don't have a lot to invest
in factories and everything,
so it's hard for them to build
a steel plant or a petrochemical
plant,
that takes a lot of bucks and a
lot of know how.
What about producing a teacher?
Is that an expensive or a cheap
proposition?
Teaching is labor intensive,
it's not capital intensive,
you need maybe a chalkboard and
some chalk and some places don't
even have that.
Education, being labor
intensive, it is one of the
cheap things that countries can
do.
Basically even the poorest
country can have surplus labor,
largely female,
and give it a minimal amount of
training.
All you have to do is make them
basically literate and they can
go out into the villages and
teach children to read and to
write,
which is amazing progress,
and then that bootstraps
itself.
If you look at developing
countries, that's one of the
things they really invest in.
First, primary education and
they get a big return from that;
they have the finances to do
that.
In fact, almost all developing
countries also have a pretty
good university structure,
not a research level university
but a teaching university.
If you look at places--they're
producing doctors--
I don't know if you know this,
but in America something like
half of all the doctors that get
licensed are trained abroad.
Now some of them are from
England, Sweden,
Germany that are training them
pretty much the way we are.
But, more are coming in from
India,
Pakistan, Philippines,
places like that,
and the people are just as
smart as anywhere else,
they maybe work harder,
more ambitious,
maybe it's harder even to get
into but they can train
thousands and thousands of
doctors.
A medical school class in
Mexico City would be like 3,000
students or something,
the law classes are all very,
very huge because it's cheap
and the marginal cost if you
already have a class in
physiology with somebody
lecturing,
add another 100 students
doesn't cost you anything.
Education up to very high
levels is something that
developing countries can often
afford because it's a labor
intensive occupation.
When you think of the brain
drain, what happens then is you
get more doctors than India can
support,
more doctors than Mexico can
so they want to come to the
United States and you get the
brain drain.
The most highly educated people
from all these developing
countries,
which the government has
invested in to pay for their
education,
they go to England,
they go to America,
they go to France,
they go to Japan,
if they're allowed in,
and they get a job.
That's the old style
brain-drain, where the people
physically move to here,
but it's also the modern job
flight that now,
again as I said,
with the internet and cheap
shipping costs all these jobs
can stay in India or somewhere
and we ship the jobs out,
the accounting.
Accounting is done in the
daytime, banks do all kinds of
transactions,
they ship all that data
overnight to India and during
our night,
which is India's day,
the Indian accountants work on
it and by the morning you have
all your accounts settled.
Engineering is worked on in
Chicago during the day and then,
however far the plans have got,
is shipped off to again,
usually India,
and the architects there work
on it and ship it back to
Chicago,
and that's increasing.
One of the important factors in
this is basically the cheapness
of education,
that education is a labor
intensive operation and so
developing countries can do it
quite well.
Within the developing
countries, they can rather
rapidly produce a lot of say
college educated people,
and these people expect good
jobs.
They've risen up,
maybe by a great amount of
effort,
risen up from the utter poverty
in their villages and now they
have a college education and
they're ready for a job.
The country usually doesn't
have jobs for them,
the economy is not yet
developed, so what is there--
there's a tremendous demand
for--for white collar jobs.
And if they don't get these
white collar jobs,
there is tremendous unrest
among the young educated people;
they're very verbal,
they know each other,
they know how to communicate,
they're mobile,
you can have a very unstable
political situation develop
right away.
The governments in all these
places almost always respond
with government jobs,
since there isn't--the private
sector is not yet capable of
producing jobs,
there's government jobs.
You get these enormously
bloated bureaucracies in almost
every underdeveloped country
where,
to do the tiniest little thing
you need 16 different people to
stamp it,
sign it, and approve it,
and it takes three days for
each of these people to make a
decision.
That's sort of--things get out
of whack when--
because it's cheap you can
produce a lot of education but
then you can't them jobs and
once you establish these big
bureaucracies,
then further economic
development may become difficult
because to do the slightest
thing,
build a factory or do something
new or import something you have
to go through all this
bureaucracy.
Because the government doesn't
have money to pay these people,
they get paid very poorly,
so corruption;
if you give us a very small
bribe this is a wonderful thing
for the bureaucrat,
so he'll pay attention to your
thing and only take two days
instead of three days to approve
whatever it is you've given him.
Again, this is the problem of
the relation between demography
and international and economic
development in poor countries.
It's all these interlocking
things;
the demography always
interlocks with every other
aspect of your economic
development.
In terms of the whole picture
of the changes in the world,
probably this is the kind of
sequence--
we've talked about a lot of
different factors that happen to
bring people into modernity.
I want to sort of summarize a
lot of that.
The first thing that apparently
happens,
it starts in the renaissance in
the West and continues on into
the enlightenment,
and then the industrial
revolution.
The first thing that happens is
people stop thinking
supernaturally about things and
start thinking about the real
world and trying to think
rationally about it.
Technological progress ensues
and allows them better shipping,
better navigation,
they get all the way to
America,
discover American foods,
bring them back and start a
population increase in Europe.
Good ways to prevent disease
are discovered,
industrial revolution increases
productivity,
you start thinking rationally
about things and everything can
get better.
More food means less death and
so population increases and this
starts in the 1700s in Europe
and really starts--
1900s in the currently
developing countries and we saw
before that sometime--
that the relationship between
mortality drop and fertility
drop was not a given,
but in almost all cases,
whether they went in parallel
and mortality was below
fertility.
Since early time,
population has been increasing
and,
even in an agrarian society,
that means as population
increases the pressure on the
land is going to go up and
you're going to get tinier and
tinier plots until you reach a
crisis.
Now, some places--Remember what
a surprise we had that England,
which was industrially
advanced, its urbanization was
advanced,
its education was advanced,
everything was advanced,
but it had one of the latest
fertility transitions.
Why?
Maybe because of primogeniture,
that they didn't have that kind
of pressure on the land because
only the oldest son inherited
and the land plots did not get
smaller and smaller.
The political structure was
such that the landed gentry were
the ones that controlled
parliament and the cities really
didn't count that much where the
excess people were,
so England did not experience
the same kind of tinier and
tinier plots and the vast
amounts of rural poverty that
other places had.
Anyway, with the scarcity of
land,
the plots gets smaller and huge
number--
in most places--huge numbers of
people fall into this abject
kind of rural poverty.
Then the two things that I've
talked about today or one of the
things that I've talked about
today happens next.
First, individual families have
to figure out a new strategy,
they realize that education for
kids is the only way out of
their situation and that means
that they have to have fewer
children.
At the same time,
with respect to the currently
developing countries,
the Western governments either
out of the goodness of their
heart or because they're scared
about revolution,
and communism,
and anti-Americanism,
they have to help the third
world so they start supporting
family programs and what they do
is two things.
One, they buy advertising and
just setting up clinics,
the social, the cultural
acceptability of controlling
fertility by some sort of
contraception becomes
acceptable.
It's not anymore a totally
taboo topic, and then they
actually provide the goods
themselves so it allows people
to work.
Their economic interest is in
having fewer children but if
they're--
if there are not the
contraceptives available as say
in China,
there was for a long time,
or it's not culturally
acceptable,
they can't act on that desire.
Family planning programs come
in, either government ones or
foreign supported ones;
their own government supported
ones or foreign ones and that
allows people to act on their
desires to have fewer children.
Then fertility falls because
they're now using some sort of
contraception and then,
as we saw, I guess last
lecture, that when fertility
falls then you get this bulge of
workers and the economy takes
off.
So that's kind of a way of
putting the whole thing
together.
Now this is all very nice
theory that I proposed to you
and you notice there's not too
many data slides that I put up
for this.
It sounds great,
I'm sure you're all convinced;
yeah that's a good answer.
When you start looking at this
in more detail things don't turn
out to be so convincing.
One, about the cost of children
going up, which is the first
part with children as a
consumption good.
Well what did children actually
need?
They need some clothing,
they need some food,
that's basically what they need
to stay alive and that's all
that they got in the old days.
Well what's happened to the
price of clothing in the last
several decades?
No, the price of clothing all
around has fallen tremendously.
Clothing with the new fabrics,
you can't wear them out at all.
I have that problem,
I can't throw things away so my
clothes just are all -- it's
very cheap, it's made in China,
Bangladesh, all around the
world.
The price of clothing has
dropped tremendously as a
fraction of income,
you always have to do that as a
fraction of income.
The price of food has dropped
around the world as a fraction
of income,
so the basic necessities of
children have really dropped and
dropped quite drastically when
you see a graph of that it's
quite drastic.
If you consider the cost of
providing the same goods that
pre-transition people provided
for their kids,
if it's a cost to providing
that now has gone way down as a
fraction of income.
As I said, often--usually
education is provided free by
the government and sometimes
healthcare is provided free by
the government.
It doesn't look like an
economic issue that if you want
to just have kids the way you
used to have them the cost has
not risen but the cost has gone
down.
What has changed is in the
minds of people they now
perceive that they must provide
for their children a completely
expand--
different and expanded set of
goods than previously.
Children have to have the kind
of education that they never had
before.
They have to have enrichment
activities, all kinds of stuff.
If you read about China,
I mean it's amazing what
Chinese--they only have one
child and that child is so over
programmed it makes you look
lazy.
I mean they go to dancing
lessons and music lessons,
and English lessons,
all after school,
the kids are just working like
crazy.
You may have noticed near the
beginning,
but not at the beginning of the
previous lecture,
a whole bunch of Chinese came
in and sat over there,
they were the Presidents of the
student--
I didn't know who they were,
they turned out to be the
Presidents of the Student
Associations at some of the
really big universities in
China.
So these are--to get to be a
top dog in a huge university is
a big deal.
What were they interested in?
This issue of modernization,
that they're spoiled,
they realize that,
they were telling me--
I spoke to them later,
that they didn't want to have a
sibling,
they were really enjoying
getting everything as an only
child,
and they did not want a sibling.
She's laughing because you know
that story.
The other side of the coin is,
as the only child they have to
succeed.
They have to get top grades in
their education,
so the amount of pressure on
them to work like crazy all the
time to study,
study, study is severe.
They were interested
in--largely in the pressures on
them which they were feeling.
I guess as Presidents of their
student body's they were
probably overachievers like
crazy and so they would feel
this pressure enormously.
Then you hear other stories
where kids learn to play this
game,
so if a parent wants them--why
don't you wash the dishes
tonight or help around the
house,
‚Äòoh if I do--if I take
time away from my studying,
I'll fail my course.'
It's this change in mentality
that has raised the cost of
childrearing,
it's not the actual--that the
actual cost of child raising.
If you raised them the old way,
that went way down,
but there's been a culture
change that's required an
enormous increase in the
expenditures on children.
Of course nowadays for you,
parents don't expect probably
anything from you in return as
an investment,
just to pay one year of Yale is
probably more than some Chinese
might make in their whole life.
Now opportunity cost is another
interesting thing.
We talked about the mother's
time, so as you remember,
the cost of children is not
just what you spend in cash but
it's the opportunity cost of
childcare time.
If you're out doing childcare
you don't have the option to
also work at that.
Studies have shown that it's
actually the time cost of
children that way outweighs the
direct cost of buying things for
them and 70% of the cost of a
child is in the value of the
time spent on it.
As people get richer,
yes, they buy more for their
children and they buy more
expensive things but their
earning power also rises and
it's this rise in earning power
that makes the 70%--
so that 70% of the cost of
children is the time they're not
spending working.
When the people go out and do
these time study things,
I don't know how well you can
see this,
but this is the amount of time
that a mother spends in
childcare for her children.
If it's one child it's 2.2
hours a day and even up to 6--
when they have 5 to 6 children,
the wife is not employed,
so this is a stay at home mom,
it's 1.9 hours.
There's really no significant
difference depending on the
number of children that you
have.
This is upstate New York in,
I think, the 1950s,
this is fairly recent,
this is not even a developing
country.
The amount of time spent is
actually quite small.
Now compare this to the mother
getting a job,
she's--so people work 40 hours
a week,
say if it's 9 to 5 and if they
don't get paid for the half hour
of lunch they can--
they work eight hours a day and
depending on how you do lunch it
can be 8.5 or 9 hours,
and then they have to commute
maybe a half an hour to work and
a half an hour back with--
getting properly dressed for
the job and commuting and
actually getting there,
so we're talking 9,10 hours a
day that a working mother,
in this case,
but it could be a father,
is away from home,
so that's the cost of having a
job is like 10 hours,
the cost of having any number
of children,
I mean seven to nine then
something different is going on,
and remember it's only about
two hours a day.
The cost in time of children is
not really all that great,
and the only time it gets
bigger is if the child is less
than one year old,
which it takes three or four
hours a day to take care of
children.
Now this is for all the members
of the family,
this is just the mother,
this is all members of the
family so again--
now this is 2.7 compare that to
2.2--
they have one child,
it's a half hour,
the other members of the family
together put a half an hour into
the child is 2.3,
this is a little bigger,
but it's never more than an
hour a day put into the child
for all the other things.
Again, it doesn't change an
awful lot with a lot of
children;
later children are cheap
because there's basically little
incremental cost to that.
Here's more recent data and
this--the red line here is
mother's childcare and this is
per week, this is not per day;
it's something that starts out
in the 1960s and 1970s which is
comparable to the data you just
saw.
It was nine;
ten hours a week which is just
a little bit over an hour a day,
and time goes on and I'll talk
about that later.
It increases but it's very
small and here's the father's
housework, it's like 2.5 hours a
day.
It's not--the amount of time it
takes to deal with children,
although our myth is that it's
very,
very time consuming,
the actual fact when you take
the data it doesn't really work
out that way.
Now you have to be careful,
this is extra time,
so this--if you do house--these
numbers are extra time so even
if you have no children it takes
a certain amount of time to take
care of a house so that's a
fixed thing.
Then all these numbers ask how
much extra time you're spending
if you have children,
so it compares people without
children to people with children
and of course that's the proper
number that we want.
Here is an interesting thing,
so as this data gets more
sophisticated,
you say well does childcare
mean?
When you take no children and
compare it to people with
children,
but if you look differently at
what the mother is actually
doing sometimes it's her primary
activity,
she's actually doing the
child--not really doing--
if anything else she's doing it
secondary like watching TV or
washing the dishes so I know
that's primary and that's an
hour and a half a day.
If it's primary or secondary,
so she may be washing the
dishes or vacuuming and the kid
is right there and she's talking
to the kid and playing with it a
little bit,
it goes up a little bit.
But it's still--this is pretty
much the same number you've seen
in the two previous slides so
there are a couple hours a day,
this is again per day,
and the other slide was per
week.
If you just count the time
they're with the children at
all,
they can both be watching
television together or they're
not really doing childcare
they're just with the children,
it's still--it gets to be more
significant but this is not time
taken away from anything else,
just the child happens to be
there.
Now--and this is moderately
stable, it doesn't change
between '65 and '98,
about the same,
a little bit different,
about the same.
Now there's something
interesting that you might have
missed in the slides.
I know I have to stop in a
minute, what happens between
1965 and 1998?
We're in the previous graph
between 1965 and 2003?
Women go to work,
there's a huge difference in
the number of women--
the fraction--either both the
number and the fraction of women
working between any of these
ages.
Yet what do you see?
The amount of time that the
mother spends in childcare goes
up from the total during this
period 9 to 10 hours up to like
14 hours.
That as women go to work they
spend more time with their
children;
part of the answer to that is
this is in the rest of house
care,
non-child house care,
and with modern gadgets and
throwaway stuff that amount has
allowed women to spend more time
with children.
Again, all this goes to
contradict that part of the
economic theory that says that
childcare competes with working
and the evidence is very,
very skinny on that hypothesis.
In fact, if you ask your
mothers or any woman that has
children, what goes away when
they go to work?
Not childcare.
Leisure time and sleep;
survey after survey says that
what women do differently when
they work is they get less sleep
and less leisure time.
I guess that's all we can do
today, see you Thursday.
We may not continue on this
topic, I think you get the idea.